hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
aspects of the stoic view of the
universe in general and on human beings
as well fits into what they would call
their physics but we would now adays
call philosophy of religion and it's
this doctrine of Providence or pronoia
and the Greek now the Stoics believed
that there was a God with a capital G
you could say those right but he was
totally unlike what people have depicted
it in him as he's not this old guy with
a beard who goes around impregnating all
sorts of human women getting his wife
angry at him etc etc instead God is the
principal running throughout the entire
universe you know you might say the
divine mind within everything imminent
not not transcendence who is outside of
the universe but imminent within the
universe and God is you know
hyper-rational that is he's rational to
the fullest extent beyond our capacities
even to to fully understand he is why is
he is you know pick all these
superlative terms
we can use you know there were other
discussions about where did the gods
small G fit in and we're not going to
worry too much about that because the
victus doesn't really say that much
about that he thinks in terms of the
divine hold a host right or it says and
before we go into the discussion about
Providence itself let's look at the
different positions that he lays out as
live possibilities in Chapter 12 of book
1 he says that there's five main ones he
thinks that there's good reason to
assert that the fifth one is actually
true but he understands that different
people throughout history up until this
point if you were around today he would
say this goes as well have held
different positions and they've arrived
at that because that seemed reasonable
to them so the first one is simply
atheism God doesn't exist there is
nothing divine and so we don't have to
think about this any further whether
there's divine providence or anything
like that because it's a non-starter no
god no province yeah some of the you
know viewpoints on the Epicurean
assembly Epicureans are basically yes
but the Epicureans actually would fit
into the second class there were a few
people who did say well there are no
divine things it's all just random you
know events or you know the universe
itself
not too many although you know we find a
lot in our own time the next position
was that the divine exists or the gods
exist or whatever you want to call them
but they're being active and indifferent
and this would indeed be the position of
the Epicureans the epicurean said the
gods exist and the reason why they're
not involved with human beings is
precisely because their gods they're
smart
that would get them into all sorts of
troubles and and give them problems to
deal with them they don't want that sort
of you know castle so they just live
their blessed existence elsewhere there
they're sort of what we call that Deus
ot osis and Latin a guy who doesn't do
anything a lazy guy right there's you
know the God of all hundred viewpoints
could fit in there I suppose but it's
you know you might say why have God's at
all well you know there's a sort of
concession to popular view as I suppose
but also gave them something to aim for
now the third one it is getting more and
more interesting God exists or the gods
exist there is something divine and it
does take a forethought it's interested
in something but what's it interested in
not on the stuff down here but only in
the great things that are happening in
the heavens we might say you know the
biggest conception of God that we see
coming about later on and the
Enlightenment fits in with this God
takes some forethought but only for the
generalities that govern the universe
that's not so that's another position
the fourth position is that God takes
some forethought
for general human manners
so God cares about things like is the
nation of Rome going to prosper or fail
and God might be interested in
particular figures like you know Julius
Caesar insofar as Julius Caesar and
Pompey ad have some sort of stadia in
there right well God's not that worried
about the little people that everybody
you know God is interested in the big
picture you know we might think of this
as sort of like the God of Hegel in many
respects if
think about his views of sweep of
history and development but there were a
lot of people who were asserting things
like that at the time that you know the
gods they exist but they're not
necessarily interested in you know the
very tiny my new show of what somebody
is doing you know who is not an
important personage that we have the
fifth position and this is what the snow
it's actually thought this is what
Epictetus thinks that the divine takes
for thought for all manners particular
as well as general down to you know the
proverbial gospel Sparrow this is
similar to the other conceptions of God
that we see floating around at the time
both in traditional pagan religion and
coming on the scene in Judaism and
Christianity and this is what MIT is
actually himself teaches as the Orthodox
stoic viewpoint so let's explore that
viewpoint now in chapter 6 he tells us
the most about Providence but also in
chapter 14 there's there's quite a bit
of important material as well he says in
chapter 6 that the universe and all the
things in it are arranged providentially
and this again is you know not something
he's coming up with on his own you can
see this if you read Cicero's on the
nature of the gods and look at the
stomach's view
Epictetus is just you know stressing it
and then reinterpreting it very vivid
terms
Epictetus things that the lesser things
like plants and animals are not only you
know taken care of my by God God made
them in such a way that they'll say
reproduce they'll you know manage to
keep themselves alive they will do the
sort of things that they're designed to
do but they're also created and ordered
for human existence so you know
Epictetus thinks that the animals that
we have been able to harvest and turn to
our own uses that is because providence
has arranged things in such a way that
that would become possible for us now
human being
are a higher stage the you might say the
great ladder of being and human beings
share something in common with the
divine we're gonna talk about this more
in another court cuts of video
specifically human relations to the
divine but the upshot of this is that
animals are able to as epic uses use
appearances that is they interact with
their environment right so they they see
another animal of their own sword and
they feel a kind of fellow feeling
towards it unless perhaps it's mating
season in which case it might be a
rivalry or there could be a turf war or
you know one institution of dominance or
they're gonna paint with each other or
you know however we go on you know they
see one of their own kind being attacked
by another animal perhaps they get
involved in the fight there's all these
things that that go into them they react
to their environment in ways that are
determinately ordered to that kind of
animal there's you know we know nowadays
that there's quite a bit of plasticity
in that's quite a bit more than the
ancients perhaps we're able to observe
but epictetus could account for that
that's not you know sort of a major
killer for his point of view what's
really important is that we human beings
not only use but understand so we can
take a position reflexive position on
our own use of appearances this is what
stoic philosophy does and saying hey
it's not the death itself that's
terrible it's your fear of death that is
making death seem terrible to you that
is a reflexive stands that's possible
because we understand and because we
understand there's also the possibility
for misunderstanding of going astray we
are probably the most screwed up
creature in the world from the
philosophers because there are so many
different ways in which unlike animals
who tend to develop more more or less
instinctually we can go off the rails in
many ways and our cultures often gear us
towards towards making bad choices like
that but we are part of the providential
order and we have a unique role in it
Epictetus goes on to say that not only
do we act within the providential order
and not only are we there to be
spectators of it so that we can see it
in a way that animals can't we're there
to be part of the interpretation the
exited gate a the universe of Providence
we have a role that elevates us not to
the status of gods but which promotes us
to become part of what epictetus is
going to call the Divine Commonwealth
when we're talking about stoic
cosmopolitanism which I will talk about
in another video this is an important
aspect to it it's not just that all
human beings are part of one big family
or we're gonna make a vast you know
household or sharing or something like
that it's that we're also doing that
with what sets up and orders the
universe we have that capacity for for
Epictetus and we can interpret it in all
these different ways we could say that
God is doing a terrible job God is doing
you know okay guys doing a great job I
don't know why God only cares about the
high-and-mighty and that us little
people you know all these are available
possibilities for us precisely because
of this is Faculty of rationality that
we possess now epictetus himself says
that the proper response on the human
beings part to the providential order is
twofold it's to try to adopt a
systematic view this thing is you know
so we know a rock decay you know what
does that mean it's sort of like seeing
everything all connected you know
looking at it from from top not just
looking at it from our own individual
self-centered perspectives but seeing
ourselves as part of a larger whole so
you use as examples you know like for
example the foot the foot he says it's
not in this in this particular chapter
but in other chapters the foot doesn't
really like to get stuck in the mud
understandably so right it's not a
pleasant experience
unless you're I guess a month fetishist
okay there's probably such a thing I
suppose if you google it but if it's
what's good for the human being as a
whole then the foot can say oh well
that's that's my job and walk through
this month's the other parts don't have
to do this well it's the same with us
human beings it's very easy for us to
adopt very self-centered perspectives
and say all the universe is screwed up
you know why me
Oh God why do you test me with all of
this nonsense that you impose on me and
Epictetus oh well you're just not taking
a broad enough of you as a matter of
fact God he says this is there God has
given us the faculty is to be able to
respond to the sort of difficulties that
we need to you know if you find yourself
being jealous or envious you have
faculties to deal with it you can reason
with yourself and steer yourself towards
the sort of Magnum E or or you know
untroubled this with respect that if you
find yourself suffering lust
you know you common experience in
ancient times as well as our own
you have temperance that you can choose
to incorporate into your life and follow
and you'll be okay you won't be
necessarily drawn into it if you go
wrong it's actually not so much God's
fault as your own he would say the other
thing that these things is very
important is a sense of gratitude in
recovery stone hearth is is a word that
can be translated it has grace in the
New Testament it's often translated as
something like a happy feeling elation
but it also means you know that this
this back and forth of gratitude and so
every stone is kind of making it even
more intensive and the idea is that when
we look at how things are arranged we
want to feel not only good because
they're good for us we want to feel a
sense of you know goodness towards
whatever he has arranged things in this
way a little bit later on in chapter 14
he's dealing with a very interesting
question how does God in fact
perceive this whole universe if if
indeed here it does you know if you're
asserting that that God takes care about
everything somehow God actually has to
be overseeing any things so how does
that happen
he says you know he gives a long
argument here which I'm going to
summarize a bit you see how God you know
has everything else doing what it's
supposed to do you know plants shoot
forth in the spring and they reproduce
and all of that he says are the plants
in our own body is so closely bound up
with the universe and do they so
intimately shares affections and is it
not the same much more true of our own
Souls our own personalities if we want
to say that the universe is arranged in
such
way that there's a cosmic order to it we
ourselves are part of that cosmic order
not only are our bodies but our minds
our souls our personalities and so he
goes on and you know he says look those
are more like God than those other
things he says if our souls are so bound
up with God and joined together with him
as being parts and portions of his being
does God not perceive their every motion
as being a motion of that which is his
own and of one body with himself and you
have the power to think about the divine
dispensation and about each several item
among things divine and at the same time
about human affairs so do you think that
God doesn't doesn't have that all this
you do is gotten and able to oversee all
things and to be present with all and
they have a certain communication from
them all another objection that gets
made a little bit later it is well I
can't follow all these things at the
same time an epic Tina says well you're
not God right I mean why assume that you
would be able to follow all these things
you're just a human being they says does
anyone go so far as to tell you this
that you possess a faculty which is
equal to that of Zeus so the idea there
is that God would you know we don't we
don't actually have to be able to
explain in complete detail how it is
that God is able to understand and take
care for all things in part because
we're one of those things that is part
of that exact grand cosmic rational
order so long story short Epictetus is a
firm believer and a great advocate of
divine providence and he leaves out how
do we you want to not only understand it
but how we want to respond to it